[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il peut vous raconter l'histoire hisire
de trois générations et pourtant ce
n'est jamais qu'un
violon il verse les enfants il marie les
plus grand c'est l'ami de toute la
maison son corps est pied du bois de
l'arbre de la vérité ces corps dont une
voix que l'on ne peut pas imiter c'est
un livre
d'histoire
violon mon
père il a attend de
mémoir le viol on
[Musique]
demandait un jour il m'a offert une
guitare pour m'amuser et depuis je ne
l'ai jamais quitté c'est lui qui m'a
donné cette envie de chanter que
j'aimerais vous faire
partager et toute mon enfance que je
revis à chaque fois que je vois ce qui
dan ou bien qui pleure quand il est là
c'est un livre
d'histoire le violon de mon père
ilend de
mémoir
viol
[Musique]
mon
sur le bateau où nous allions chercher
notre avenir nous lui avons confié nos
souvenirs il les a bien gardés et si
vous en doutez il vous suffit de lui
demander vous l'entendrez gémir quand il
évoque nos malheurs vous le verrez
sourire quand il raconte le bonheur
c'est un livre
d'histoire le viol de mon père re il
attend de
mémoir le violon de mon père c'est un
livre
d'histoire le viuxom de mon père il att
tend de
mémoire le violon de mon père le violon
de mon
père
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]